[Musique]
elle tombe et leurs descendants la
poubelle et les crevards des
cambrioleurs et wall street il fallait
peut-être venu appeler la police par
précaution de qui se moque t'on c'est la
troisième fois que votre gamin alerte la
terre entière pour rien du tout et vous
le croyez encore
c'est le monde à l'envers vous êtes le
gardien vous n'êtes même pas foutu de
garder votre propre petit fils ce serait
bien que tu prennes ton petit-déjeuner
temps en temps accueilli madame wang
liquin prix moral 1 quand elle ne pas
pas un casse couille t'étonne pas si
personne va être ton ami tu passes ton
temps à mentir
[Musique]
pied vous soyez mon frère et fermez là
on vient juste de braquer une bijouterie
c'est celle là celle là c'est la petite
soeur des deux grands abreu dit enfin
jouer tous les deux vous désirez
tu trouves et l'avenue promis comme
[Musique]
aussi vous leurs pions
beyou
un problème mais vous êtes tous d'ici là
bien que si les fouilles et euros
donc c'est la loose en aurait deux
femmes ayant pas